4 esta Nueva Ola de ataques sobre
Ucrania responde a una necesidad de
llegar al 9 de mayo con resultados
cercanos en la guerra o son parte de una
estrategia mayor
digamos siempre las fechas simbólicas
generan alguna acción digamos más
altisonante era muy previsible que
frente a la ausencia de alguna Victoria
militar importante como se pensó algunos
meses atrás que puede hacer la caída de
bacmut no porque fuera clave la ciudad
pero sí implicara un avance por fin del
ejército ruso en una guerra en una
batalla muy muy difundida en los medios
en los últimos ocho nueve meses esa
ciudad sigue sin caer envuelta en todo
un escándalo entre la fuerza Wagner que
denuncia al ejército ruso que no lo
ayuda toda una telenovela poco usual en
el tradicional verticalismo que que
rigen la estructura de defensa y
militares de Rusia y antes de la unión
soviética
este desfile la verdad que Putin tiene
poco para mostrar digamos no De hecho no
ha habido avances en todo en todo el fin
del año pasado y principio de este y
indica que al fin de la primavera
principio del verano en el norte vamos a
tener algún tipo de ofensiva
ucraniana por lo tanto Creo que este
nuevo de nueve de mayo no es el nueve de
mayo que que esperaba Putin es el
segundo nueve de mayo que Putin no
esperaba que fuera así uno fue el del
año pasado cuando ya pensaba tener a
Ucrania en sus manos y este segundo
donde las cosas no no se han revertido
sustancialmente su guerra que está en
status quo ya hace más de un año
precisamente sobre esto quería
preguntarle sobre cómo llega a Rusia
esta celebración Porque desde el kremlin
se ha buscado un ensalzamiento del
nacionalismo pero se llega a esta fecha
con cientos de muertos en Bad mood sin
controlar por completo El donbas y con
hipotéticas fallas de seguridad en Moscú
están Por tanto la sociedad Rusia rusa
cohesionada en torno a la guerra o la
posición de Putin es quizás más débil
que antes
las encuestas serias que hay que no que
no son muchas porque en el gobiernos
autoritarios las encuestas son digamos
son usualmente no muy fiables pero
aquellas que usualmente manejan ciertos
ámbitos académicos o de inteligencia de
occidente que reflejan la opinión
pública rusa verdadera muestran que
todavía hay un consenso en torno en
torno a esta guerra hay una bandera
nacionalista yo creo que este ataque
este mini ataque que un Mini drones que
hubo sobre el kremlin si no se trató de
de un ataque de extremistas ruso que
quiere una guerra más grande todavía una
especie de falsa bandera para
alentar un poco el espíritu del
nacionalismo ruso antes del nueve de
mayo pero es la guerra que que Rusia se
ha resignado que se transforma en una
guerra de desgaste con altísimas bajas
que no no es la que se esperó cuando
inicia esta operación en febrero del año
2022 no Rusia se ha readaptado lo que
iba a ser una Guerra Relámpago se parece
cada vez más a la película 1917 que ganó
el Oscar no batalla de trinchera barro
lluvia
escasos retrocesos escasos avances Pero
bueno no es la primera vez que Rusia
tiene la la voluntad política de de
plantarse en una guerra de este tipo
pero no es lo no es lo esperado y este
desfile del nueve no es un desfile de la
Victoria precisamente sin duda